As the crispy chicken sandwich from 7-Eleven, people always call me loud. And I'm like, yeah, I know. I'm crispy. Did you expect me to whisper? If you want quiet, go eat some soup and reflect. Like, I know I'm a handful. I'm bold, I'm juicy. Throw some pickles and barbecue sauce on me, and baby, I'm a whole meal. And with seven rewards, I'm just $4.
就像7-Eleven的香脆鸡肉三明治，大家总说我动静很大。而我想说，对啊，我知道。我很脆。难道你希望我跟你说悄悄话吗？如果你想要安静，去喝点汤反思一下吧。我这人就是很难搞，我张扬、我多汁。在我身上加点酸黄瓜和烧烤酱，宝贝，我就是一整顿大餐。而且有了7-Eleven的奖励积分，我只要4块钱。
Quiet. No. Krispy, saucy, and $4? Very. Only at 711. Valley 362326, participating stores only while supplies lastly out for full terms. In the past few months, artificial intelligence has been all over the news. We're all trying to figure out how to live in a world where everything from college essays to wedding vows to mental health advice can be outsourced to a chatbot.
安静。才不。又脆又多汁还只要4块钱？非常可以。仅限7-Eleven。山谷362326，仅限参与活动的门店，售完即止。有关完整条款请查看详情。在过去的几个月里，人工智能一直充斥着各大新闻。我们都在努力弄清楚，在一个从大学论文、结婚誓言到心理健康建议都可以外包给聊天机器人的世界里，该如何生活。
Meanwhile, the rollout of some AI systems hasn't been entirely smooth. The National Eating Disorders Association, for example, replaced its human-staffed helpline with an AI chatbot, but took it offline after it started giving problematic advice. So today we're going to be talking about how artificial intelligence works, how AI connects to and differs from human cognition, and how studying human cognition could help researchers improve AI systems. So what's going on inside the black box of AI? In what ways are the AI systems we're using similar to human cognition, and in what ways are they different? How is AI changing the way scientific research, including psychological research, is being done? And more broadly, how will it change our lives in the future?
与此同时，一些人工智能系统的推出并非一帆风顺。例如，美国全国进食障碍协会用人工智能聊天机器人的客服热线取代了人工客服，但在它开始提供有问题的建议后，便将其下线了。因此，今天我们将讨论人工智能是如何工作的，人工智能与人类认知有何联系与区别，以及研究人类认知如何帮助研究人员改进人工智能系统。那么，人工智能的黑箱里究竟发生了什么？我们正在使用的人工智能系统在哪些方面类似于人类认知，在哪些方面又有所不同？人工智能将如何改变科学研究（包括心理学研究）的开展方式？更广泛地说，它将如何在未来改变我们的生活？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Tom Griffiths, a professor of psychology and computer science and director of the Computational Cognitive Science Lab at Princeton University. He's interested in developing mathematical models of human thinking and decision-making, and in exploring how human cognition connects to ideas from artificial intelligence, machine learning, and statistics. He's the author of many scientific papers and of a book called Algorithms to Live By,
欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客节目，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是汤姆·格里菲斯（Tom Griffiths）博士，他是普林斯顿大学心理学和计算机科学教授，也是计算认知科学实验室的主任。他致力于开发人类思维和决策的数学模型，并探索人类认知如何与来自人工智能、机器学习和统计学的思想相结合。他是许多科学论文的作者，也是《生活中的算法》（Algorithms to Live By）一书的作者。
about the parallels between the everyday problems that arise in human lives and the problems faced by computers and what we can learn from computer scientists about how to solve those problems. Dr. Griffiths, thank you for joining me today. Thanks, Kim. Great to be here. As I mentioned in the intro, AI is everywhere in the news right now, and it seems like it's becoming smarter all the time.
该书探讨了人类生活中出现的日常问题与计算机面临的问题之间的相似之处，以及我们能从计算机科学家那里学到如何解决这些问题。格里菲斯博士，非常感谢您今天能来到节目中。谢谢你，金。很高兴来到这里。正如我在开场白中所提到的，人工智能现在在新闻中无处不在，而且它似乎每时每刻都在变得更聪明。
So let me start with a broad question. What are humans still better at than artificial intelligence? And on the flip side, what does AI do better than we do? Well, I think one way of thinking about it is to think about what the differences are between the kinds of computational problems that human minds have to solve and the kinds of computational problems that AI has to solve. So if you think about humans, we are biological organisms that have limited lifetimes, that have a limited amount of computation, what we carry around inside our heads, and they have limited capacity for communication. We have to do what we're doing right now, moving our lips and making honking noises, in order to get bits from my brain into your brain. brain. And an AI system doesn't have those same constraints, right? AI systems can learn from huge amounts of data. Many of the AI systems we're dealing with right now are trained on the
那么，请允许我从一个宏观的问题开始。人类目前有哪些方面依然比人工智能做得更好？反过来，人工智能又有哪些方面比我们做得更好？嗯，我认为思考这个问题的一个角度是，思考人类大脑必须解决的计算问题与人工智能必须解决的计算问题之间有什么区别。因此，如果你想想人类，我们是有寿命限制的生物，我们的计算能力有限（也就是我们脑子里装的东西），我们的沟通能力也有限。我们必须做我们现在正在做的事情，动动嘴唇，发出各种声音，才能把我大脑中的比特信息传送到你大脑中。而人工智能系统没有这些相同的限制，对吧？人工智能系统可以从海量数据中学习。我们现在正在处理的许多人工智能系统都是用
equivalent of many human lifetimes of data. They can have more and more compute as they need it. You can build bigger and bigger computers. You can wire those computers together. You can have parallel computing going on that's sort of driving up the amount of computation that those systems can access. And they can just copy the, the, things that one system has learned directly into another system. So they can transfer that information directly. And so those differences actually set up some of the things that humans are good at, some of the things that AI is good at. Right. So our limited lifetimes mean that we have to be able to learn from small amounts of data, something that AI systems are not great at right now. Our
相当于许多人类寿命的数据进行训练的。根据需要，它们可以拥有越来越多的计算能力。你可以建造越来越大的计算机。你可以把这些计算机连接起来。你可以进行并行计算，从而提升这些系统所能获取的计算能力。它们可以把一个系统学到的东西直接复制到另一个系统。因此它们可以直接传输这些信息。正是这些差异造就了人类擅长的领域和人工智能擅长的领域。没错。因此，我们有限的寿命意味着我们必须能够从少量数据中学习，而这正是人工智能系统目前所不擅长的。我们
limited computational resources means that we have to be good at using the brains that we have as efficiently as possible. And that's something that's still a challenge for AI. And our limited communication capacity means that we need to come up with ways to work together, to be able to pool the resources that we have, the data or the computation, to do the kinds of things that no human being can do on their own, creating things like language and teaching each other and culture and societies, all of which are still very human kinds of systems. How similar is the way that a system like chat, GPT, works to the way that the human brain works? And how is it different?
有限的计算能力意味着我们必须善于尽可能高效地利用我们现有的头脑。这对于人工智能来说仍然是一个挑战。我们有限的沟通能力意味着我们需要想出合作的方法，以便汇集我们所拥有的资源——数据或计算能力，去完成任何人类单枪匹马都无法完成的事情，比如创造语言、互相教学、文化以及社会，所有这些仍然是非常具人类特色的系统。像ChatGPT这样的系统的运作方式与人类大脑的运作方式有多相似？又有什么不同？
I think there's two ways of thinking about that question. One is, when we look at this system as it's been trained and sort of, you know, the behavior that it's producing, how does that behavior compare to what humans do? The other question is, how does the system learn? How does it get to the point that it's got to from all of the data that it's using? And so the second question is a little bit easier to answer because these systems require much more data than a human being to get to the point that a human being gets to by this time they're, say, you know, five years old or six years old, right? So humans in a few years of being exposed to the language around them achieve a pretty high level of competence in using language. and these kinds of systems, it takes much more data, as I was saying before, the equivalent
我认为有两种方式来思考这个问题。第一种是，当我们审视这个经过训练的系统以及它所产生的行为时，这种行为与人类的行为相比如何？第二个问题是，这个系统是如何学习的？它是如何从它所使用的大量数据中发展到今天这一步的？所以第二个问题稍微容易回答一些，因为这些系统需要比人类多得多的数据，才能达到人类在比如说五六岁时所达到的水平，对吧？因此，人类在接触周围语言几年后，就能在语言使用上达到相当高的熟练水平。而对于这类系统，正如我之前所说，需要更多的数据，相当于
of many human lifetimes of data to get to that point, right? So if we look at some of these kinds of systems like Chad ChpT, you can sort of do the numbers in a few different ways, but they're trained on, you know, at least thousands of human lifetimes worth of data. And so for learning, it's clear that, you know, the story about learning has to be something different from the way that humans are learning language. The question about how it is that these systems work and whether they are doing things that are similar to the things that are going on inside people's heads, that's still a question that I think people are trying to work out. And so there's lots of papers that are coming out where they're doing things like showing that the representations inside these systems
许多人类寿命的数据才能达到那个水平，对吧？因此，如果我们看一下ChatGPT之类的系统，你可以用几种不同的方式来计算这些数字，但它们是用至少相当于数千个辉煌人生的数据训练出来的。因此，在学习方面，显而易见，关于学习的故事肯定与人类学习语言的方式有所不同。关于这些系统是如何运作的，以及它们所做的事情是否与人们头脑中发生的事情相似，这仍然是一个人们仍在努力弄清楚的问题。因此，有很多新发表的论文都在做一些事情，比如表明这些系统内部的表征
can predict things that are going on inside people's brains. I have a paper like that with a bunch of other co-authors, but there's a few papers along those lines. And then there's lots of papers that are probing the behavior of these systems. looking at whether they do the same kinds of things that humans do when they're given the same kind of stimuli. And so that's interestingly a really good project for psychologists, right? So we as psychologists are used to investigating mysterious systems based just on their behavior. Those systems are normally human beings, but we're getting the chance to use those same research
可以预测人们大脑中正在发生的事情。我和其他好几位合著者就有一篇这样的论文，不过沿着这个方向还有好几篇论文。此外，还有许多论文在探究这些系统的行为。观察当它们被赋予相类似的刺激时，它们是否会做出与人类相同的反应。有趣的是，这对于心理学家来说是一个非常好的项目，对吧？因此，作为心理学家，我们习惯于仅根据行为来调查神秘系统。这些系统通常是人类，但我们现在有机会利用同样的科学研究
skills to try and make sense of how AI systems work. So it sounds like we're building the plane while we're flying it, and I'm just wondering, For example, how it is that some of these chatbots decide, in air quotes, to make up answers when they don't know the answer. Why don't they just come back and say, I can't find what you're looking for? That's a really interesting question, and it gets to the heart of what it means to be a chatbot. So the way that these systems are created, they're solving a very specific problem, which is how to predict the next word that somebody is going, to produce, right? That's a problem that you as a human being can do. So humans are able to do that. You know, we do that drawing on our knowledge of language and our knowledge of the world and the
技能，去试图理解人工智能系统是如何工作的。听起来我们就像是在飞行中造飞机，我只是在想，例如，当这些聊天机器人不知道答案时，它们是怎么“决定”（加引号）编造答案的？它们为什么不直接回复说，我找不到你要找的东西？这是一个非常有趣的问题，它触及了聊天机器人的本质。因为这些系统的创建方式决定了它们是在解决一个非常特定的问题，那就是如何预测某人将要产生的下一个词，对吧？这是一个你作为人类能够做到的问题。所以人类能够做到这一点。你知道，我们依靠对语言的知识、对世界的知识以及我们正在谈论的
kind of topics that we're talking about, right? And so that's the same problem that the AI system is trying to solve. So it's kind of like trying to build up, just based on the experience that it has from language, a model of the world that's good enough to help it to make that prediction of what word is going to be. And so the problem of predicting the next word is not one that sort of, you know, sets you up to think about whether that next thing is actually true or not, right? So now if you ask this system, okay, here's some text, what's a likely response to this text, it's going to generate something, which is a sort of high probability response based on all of the knowledge that it has about language, but it's not going to be saying, okay, is this true
话题来做到这一点，对吧？这也是人工智能系统试图解决的相同问题。因此，它有点像试图仅仅根据它从语言中获得的经验，建立一个足够好的世界模型，来帮助它预测下一个词会是什么。因此，预测下一个词的问题并不是一个能让你去思考接下来这个东西到底是真是假的问题，对吧？所以现在如果你问这个系统，好了，这里有一些文本，对这段文本的可能回应是什么，它会生成一些内容，这是一种基于它对语言的所有知识的高概率回应，但它不会去说，好吧，这是真的
or not, whereas a human being that you're interacting with and you're sort of having a conversation with might be thinking about whether things are true or false. So the chatbot, unlike human beings, is not willfully lying. It's just making a selection based on what's available to it. Yeah, it's not even thinking about truth or falsehood. It's just thinking about what's a plausible answer to this question. Now, in a recent story in APA's magazine, the Monitor, you said, quote, a lot of what's driving progress is the capacities that these AI systems have, and that's outstripping how well we understand how they work. That's directly quoted from you.
还是假的，而你与之互动并与之进行对话的人类可能会去思考事情是真是假。因此，聊天机器人与人类不同，它不是故意说谎的。它只是根据可供其使用的内容进行选择。是的，它甚至没有考虑真假。它只是在思考对这个问题的合理回答是什么。现在，在APA杂志《观察家》（The Monitor）最近的一篇报道中，你曾说过：“推动进展的很大一部分原因在于这些人工智能系统所具备的能力，而这已经超出了我们对其工作原理的理解程度。”这是直接引用你的话。
What did you mean by that? In what ways do we not understand how AI systems are working? Yeah, so I made this comment in the context of a proposal that was going around about taking a pause from developing AI systems. And I think that, you know, that's something which is probably important. impractical, given all of the pressures that there are around building these systems. But something that we can do is call for more research looking into how these systems work, how they are similar to people, how they're different from people. And one of the things that we're interested in is something that we call alignment, which is like, how aligned are the ways that these systems think about and represent the world when compared to the thoughts and representations of human beings?
你是什么意思？我们在哪些方面不理解人工智能系统是如何工作的？是的，我是在当时关于暂停开发人工智能系统的提议的背景下发表这一评论的。我认为，考虑到围绕构建这些系统所存在的所有压力，这可能是不大
because if you're used to interacting with another human being, you kind of have a model in your head of how that human being works and what kinds of things that human being is likely to know and what kinds of things that human being is unlikely to know. And so I think what we need to do is more research where we can work out, what are the things that these systems are sort of good at and accurate at? And what are the things where it sort of seems like they're good and accurate, but maybe they're not as accurate under the surface, and help people to have an understanding of where it's probably okay to have this interaction and probably sort of reasonably safe interaction to be having in terms of the facts that you're getting,
切实际的。但我们可以做的一件事是呼吁进行更多研究，深入探讨这些系统是如何工作的，它们与人类有哪些相似之处，又有哪些不同之处。我们感兴趣的事情之一是我们称之为“对齐”（alignment）的概念，也就是说，当与人类的思想和表征进行比较时，这些系统思考和表征世界的方式与人类的契合度有多高？因为如果你习惯于与另一个人互动，你的脑海中其实有一个模型，关于那个人是如何运作的，那个人可能知道哪些事情，以及那个人不太可能知道哪些事情。因此，我认为我们需要做更多的研究，弄清楚这些系统在哪些方面是擅长且准确的？而在哪些方面，它们看起来似乎很好很准确，但也许在表层之下并不那么准确，并帮助人们了解在哪些地方进行这种互动是可以接受的，在获取事实方面进行互动可能是相当安全的，
and cases where it may not be as accurate in the answers that it's giving you. So I can give you a concrete example from our own research, where we went in and, we asked GPT to give us estimates of how similar
而在哪些地方，它给出的答案可能没有那么准确。所以我可以从我们自己的研究中举一个具体的例子，我们去让GPT给我们估算不同的事物彼此之间有多相似或多不同，
are different things are to one another so how similar are two colors how similar are two musical notes how similar are two tastes
比如两种颜色有多相似，两个音符有多相似，两种味道有多相似。
and what we discovered was that GPT actually has a really good accurate representation of things like colors and musical notes
而我们发现的是，GPT实际上对颜色和音符等事物有着非常好且准确的表征，
that the representation has is very aligned with the way that humans think about those things but its representation
这种表征与人类思考这些事物的方式高度契合，但它对味道的表征
of tastes is quite different from the representation that humans have. And so that would tell you, if you were going to ask GPT for advice, it might be good to ask it for a wardrobe advice about what colors are going to go well together, but it might be less good to ask it for advice about a recipe that you're making where you're asking about what
与人类的表征大不相同。因此，这就告诉你，如果你要向GPT寻求建议，向它征求关于什么颜色搭配好看的衣橱建议可能是个不错的选择，但如果你向它征求关于你正在制作的食谱的建议，询问哪些食材搭配在一起好吃，它可能就不那么擅长了。心理学和心理科学在发展人工智能中应该扮演什么角色？它现在扮演的是什么角色，未来又应该扮演什么角色。我认为我们可以从两个方面来思考心理学与人工智能之间的这种关系。如果你从信息可以流动的两个方向来考虑，即从心理学到人工智能，以及从人工智能到心理学，对吧？因此，从心理学到人工智能，我们可以做的事情之一，实际上是利用我们为理解人类行为而开发出来的工具包，去真正理解这些系统在做什么、它们知道什么、以及这与人类所做的事情相对应的程度如何。
ingredients would taste well, good together. What should the role of psychology and psychological science be in developing artificial intelligence? What is it now and what should it be going forward. I think there are two ways that we can think about this relationship between psychology and AI. And if you think about it as, you know, there's the two directions that information can flow, from psychology to AI and from AI to psychology, right? So going from psychology to AI, one of the things that we can do is actually use the toolkit that we've developed for making sense of human behavior to really understand what it is that these systems are doing, what it is that they know, how well that corresponds to the kinds of things that humans do.
没错。因此，心理学家习惯于接受那些做着各种复杂事情的系统，仅仅通过它们的行为，设计我们可以运行的实验，来揭示人类头脑中可能正在发生的事情，或许对于计算机而言，在其电路内部发生的事情，从而告诉我们该系统是如何运作的，并揭示出这些我认为对人工智能来说是真正的挑战，因为许多人工智能研究人员已经习惯于生活在一个完全理解其系统在做什么的世界里，而现在突然置身于这样一个世界：我们建造了这些以我们无法完全理解的方式产生复杂行为的东西，而且无法仅仅从该系统的底层数学原理来解释。反过来，从人工智能到心理学，我认为我们得到了关于人类思维可能如何工作的各种有趣的假设，以及我们可以探索的人类行为的方面，
Right. And so psychologists are used to taking systems that are doing all sorts of complex things and just using their behavior, designing experiments that we can run in order to reveal the things that might be going on for a human being inside their head and maybe for a computer, you know, inside their circuits that tell us about how it is that that system works and revealing these things that I think are a true. challenge for AI, because a lot of AI researchers have been used to living in a world where you completely understand what your system is doing, and are now suddenly in a world where we've built
这些都是受到人工智能中使用的模型的启发。我们还获得了可以用来以不同方式开展科学研究的新工具。比如我们可以利用这些人工智能系统来设计新实验，或者构建比心理学家凭一己之力能够提出的模型或理论更好的模型。
these things that are producing complex behaviors in ways that we don't completely understand and can't explain just from the sort of the underlying mathematics of the system. Going in the other direction, from AI to psychology, I think we get all sorts of interesting hypotheses about how human minds might work and things that we can explore about human behavior. they're inspired by the models that are being used in AI. We also get new tools that we can use for doing our science differently. So ways that we can use those AI systems to design new experiments or to build better models than the kinds of models or theories that psychologists could come up with on their own.
我们花一分钟来谈谈你的研究。你的工作是制作人类认知的数学模型。用通俗的话来讲，这意味着什么？你如何用数学术语来描述人类的思考？我的研究起点其实就是人类大脑必须解决什么计算问题这个问题，对吧？这意味着，你知道，当你早晨醒来时，你有一系列关于这一天的决定要做，你知道，这就是一种计算问题，
Let's talk for a minute about your research. Your work is about making mathematical models of human cognition. What does that mean in lay terms? how do you describe human thinking in mathematical terms? So where we start in my research is really with this question of what computational problems human minds have to solve, right? And that means, you know, thinking about when you get up in the morning, you've got a series of decisions you have to make about your day, you know, that's a kind of computational problem,
对吧？这种决策，你有不同的选项。你必须在它们之间做出选择。你必须制定一个计划。你必须规划好，好吧，我必须先做这个再做那个。我必须先做这个，再做那个。这就是计算机科学家所说的规划问题，对吧？当你到达工作单位时。
right? This sort of decision making, you've got different options. You have to choose between them. You have to develop a plan. You have to plan out, okay, I have to do this before I do this. I have to do this, before I do this. That's a problem that computer scientist is called planning, right? To, you know, you arrive at work.
有一个你需要学习的新概念。有人会给你一些例子，说明什么是该概念的例子。你必须从这些例子中弄清楚它是什么。你知道，你要去选择在哪里吃午饭。有很多餐馆可供选择。你以前去过其中一些。有些是新的。你如何决定是去一个以前去过的地方，还是去一个新地方？
There's a new concept you have to learn. Someone's going to give you some examples of things that are examples of that concept. You have to figure out what it is from those examples. You know, you're going to go and choose where you're going to eat your lunch. There's a bunch of restaurants to choose from. You've been to some of them before. Some of them are new. how do you make the decision about whether you go to something you've been to before versus something new.
这些都是计算问题。所以我们要做的就是接受这些计算问题，然后思考解决这些问题的好方法到底是什么。数学告诉我们解决这些问题的理想方式是什么？然后我们利用这些数学知识回过头来试图理解人类行为。因此，当我们看待规划之类的事情时，人们使用的规划策略，是否可以用解决规划问题的数学来解释？人们学习概念的方式是否与统计学中关于如何利用数据更新信念的数学相一致？
These are all computational problems. And so what we do is take those computational problems and then think about what is actually a good way of solving those problems. What does the math tell us is the sort of ideal way of solving those problems? And then we use that math to go back and then try and make sense of human behavior. So when we look at things like planning, are the kinds of planning strategies that people use, things that we can explain in terms of the mathematics of solving a planning problem? Are the ways in which people learn concepts consistent with the mathematics that comes from statistics about how you should use data to update your beliefs?
人们选择午饭的方式是否与计算机科学中强化学习文献中关于如何解决所谓的“探索与利用权衡”（explore-exploit trade-off）的内容相一致？因此，在每一种情况下，都有一套我们可以借鉴的数学原理，我们可以用它们来回过头理解人类行为中到底发生了什么。你刚才提到人工智能如何能够积累数千代人类的所有知识。鉴于它能够综合海量数据，人工智能是如何改变科学研究的开展方式的？它又是如何改变研究人员可能会提出的问题的？
Are the way that people choose their lunch consistent with something that comes from the reinforcement learning literature and computer science about how to solve what's called the explore-exploit trade-off? And so in each of those cases, there's a set of mathematical principles that we can draw on we can use to go back and understand exactly what's going on in human behavior. You mentioned earlier how artificial intelligence is able to amass all of the knowledge of thousands of generations of human beings. How is AI changing the way that scientific research is done given the amount of data that it's able to synthesize? How does it change the kinds of
因此，随着我们拥有的数据量（特别是在心理学领域）关于人类行为的数据量的增加，这些数据有可能达到一个超出人类轻松思考范围的点，对吧。因此，这就创造了一个机会，让我们能够利用人工智能系统在处理这些类型的数据时增强人类的智能，从而想出理解这些数据的新方法，并开发出新的、有意义的科学理论。因此，我们已经开始在我的实验室里探索，我们如何能够在心理学研究的背景下使用这些方法。
questions that researchers might ask. So as the amount of data that we have, in particular in psychology, the amount of data that we have about human behavior increases, it's possible for that to get to a point where it sort of goes beyond what it's easy for a human being to think about. Right. So that creates an opportunity for us to use AI systems to augment the intelligence of humans as they're dealing with these kinds of data to come up with new ways of making sense of those data, to develop, you know, new meaningful scientific theories. And so we've begun to explore in my lab, how we can use those kinds of methods
我们通过几种不同的方式做到了这一点。其中一种方法是取一个非常大的数据集，结合一个心理学理论，然后说，我们遗漏了多少？也就是说，在解释这些数据方面，我们的理论到底有多好？因此，我们可以做的是，采用一个机器学习模型，
in the context of psychological research. So we've done this in a couple of different ways. So one way is to take a really big data set and take a psychological theory and say, how much are we missing? Like, how good is our theory really in terms of explaining these data? And so what we can do then is take a machine learning model,
将该机器学习模型拟合到数据中，也就是让机器学习模型根据行为数据做出尽可能好的预测。然后我们可以将机器学习模型的预测效果与人类科学家开发的理论的预测效果进行比较。
fit that machine learning model to the data, that is make the machine learning model make the best predictions that it can from the behavioral data. And then we can compare how good the predictions of the machine learning model are to the predictions of a theory that's developed by human scientists.
这就给我们带来了一种差距，对吧？它告诉我们差距有多大？在试图理解正在发生的事情方面，还有多少空间需要填补？实际上，我们可以利用机器学习模型的输出回过头来批判我们的心理学理论，并提出一个更好的
And that gives us a kind of gap, right? It tells us how big is the gap? How much space is there to fill in terms of trying to understand what's going on? And we can actually use the output of the machine learning model to go back and critique our psychological theory and come up with a better
理论。所以我们称之为“科学遗憾最小化”（scientific regret minimization），因为这个本意是，你应该关注那些你本可以避免却犯下的错误。机器学习模型会通过指出这一特定数据是你本可以预测却未能预测出来的东西，来告诉你哪些错误是你本可以避免的。所以这是一个策略。另一件我们可以做的事情是，实际上利用机器学习模型来帮助我们在理论空间中进行搜索。因此我们可以定义一组理论，其中包含一些将要融入其中的心理学原则，然后我们如何将这些原则组合在一起，以便对人类行为做出最佳预测。机器学习模型可以去
theory. So we call this scientific regret minimization because the idea is that you should care about the errors that you're making that you could have avoided. And the machine learning model tells you which errors you could have avoided by saying this particular piece of data was something that you could have predicted, but you failed to predict. And so that's one strategy. The other thing that we can do is actually use the machine learning model to help us search the space of theories. And so we can kind of define a set of theories where we say, here's some sort of psychological principles that are going to go into this and then how do we combine these together in order to make the best predictions about human behavior. And the machine learning model can go off
在这些理论空间中进行搜索，并就观察什么能解释数据而言，提出最好的理论。通过这样做，它为我们提供了一个工具，然后我们可以用它来处理比以前大得多的数据集。因此在最近的一篇论文中，我们使用这种策略来研究人类决策，而在以往关于决策的论文中，通常使用大约几百个决策的量级，比如在人们可能会考虑的不同博彩之间进行选择。这是一个，你知道，你想要这个奖品有10%的概率还是90%的概率，与
and, you know, search through the space of these theories and come up with the best theory in terms of, you know, seeing what explains the data. And by doing that, it gives us a tool that we can use to then work with much bigger data sets than we could previously have worked with. So in one paper recently, we used this strategy to look at human decision making, where previously papers on decision making had used on the order of about a few hundred decisions, like choices between different, you know, gambols, say, that people might be entertaining. It's a, you know, do you want a 10% chance of this prize or a 90% chance of this prize versus
这个奖品有20%的概率和80%的概率相比？这些就是我们研究人类决策的方式。因此，以前的研究使用了几百个这样的场景来试图理解人们的决策，但我们使用了大约10,000个场景，然后我们能够使用机器学习模型进入并弄清楚，哦，你知道，我们用来解释这些数据的基本心理学原则本质上是正确的，但它们并不普遍适用于整个问题空间。因此，对于某些问题，人们的表现是一种方式，而对于其他问题，人们的表现则是另一种方式。这就给我们带来了另一个
a 20% chance of this prize and an 80% chance of this prize? These are kind of the way that we investigate human decision making. So previous research had used, you know, a few hundred. of these scenarios to try and understand people's decisions, but we used more like 10,000 of them, and then we're able to use a machine learning model to go in and work out, oh, you know, the basic psychological principles we're using to explain those data are essentially correct, but they don't apply uniformly across the space of problems. So for some problems, people behave one way, for other problems, people behave another way. And that gives us another
我们现在想要能够解释的人类行为的新事物。所以从某种意义上说，这让科学变得更准确，你是这个意思吗？我认为它做了两件事。一是它使我们对人类行为的预测更加准确。二是它允许我们探索可能比我们以前能够探索的理论更复杂的理论。这只是拥有更多数据的一个自然结果，对吧？所以我们曾经生活在一个没有太多人类行为数据的世界里。
kind of thing that we now want to be able to explain about human behavior. So in a since it's making the science more accurate, is that what you're saying? It's doing two things, I think. One is it's making the predictions that we're able to make about human behavior more accurate. But the other is it's allowing us to explore theories that might be more complicated than the theories we were able to explore before. And that's a natural consequence of just having more data, right? So we used to live in a world where we didn't have very much data about human behavior.
因此我们能够想出的唯一理论就是非常简单的理论。随着你获得更多的数据，你就有机会去探索更复杂的理论。来自人工智能的这类工具为我们提供了探索这些理论所需的机制。正如我在引言中提到的，你几年前写过一本书，名为《生活中的算法》，讲述了人类可以从计算机算法中学到什么。你能稍微谈谈这个吗？我的意思是，像计算机一样思考如何能帮助我们解决日常生活中的问题？好的。我的研究是关于这两个或许表面上看起来相互矛盾的想法，对吧？
And so the only theories we could come up with a very simple theory. And as you get more data, you have the opportunity to then explore more complex theories. And these kinds of tools from AI give us the mechanisms that we need in order to be able to explore those kinds of theories. As I mentioned in the introduction, you wrote a book several years ago called Algorithms to Live By about what humans can learn from computer algorithms. Can you talk about that a little bit? I mean, how can thinking like a computer help us solve everyday problems? Right. So my research is about these two perhaps sort of apparently mutually conflicting ideas, right?
一个是人类可以从计算机那里学到什么，另一个也许是计算机可以从人类那里学到什么，对吧？《生活中的算法》一书的要点在于指出，我们在日常生活中实际上面临的许多问题，都属于这些类别。事实上，对于那个计算问题，我们知道解决方案是什么，你只需执行那个解决方案即可。所以，你知道，我刚才提到的一个例子是，如果你试图决定去哪里吃午饭，对吧，有一些地方你以前去过，有一些你可以去的新地方。你必须做出一个决定：
So one is what humans can learn from computers, and then the other is maybe what computers can learn from humans, right? And so the point of algorithms to live by was to say that many of the problems that we actually face in everyday life are things that fall into these kinds of categories. where, in fact, for that computational problem, we know what the solution is and you can just execute that solution. So, you know, an example that I mentioned earlier is if you're trying to decide where to go for lunch, right, there's some places that you've been to before, there's some new place that you could go to. You have a decision you have to make between,
我是去老地方，还是去新地方？这个问题已经被计算机科学家广泛研究过了。它被称为“探索与利用权衡”（explore-exploit trade-off）。你是去探索新事物，还是去利用你拥有的知识去老地方？有一些简单的算法你可以遵循，以便以最优方式解决该问题。其中一种算法可以这样描述：考虑你在新地方可能获得的最佳合理体验。因此，对新地方的质量抱有乐观态度。如果这种乐观的估算比你对在别处用餐质量的估算要好，那么你就应该尝试一下新地方。
do I go to the old place, do I go to the new place? This problem has been studied extensively by computer scientists. It's called the explore, exploit trade-off. Do you explore the new thing or exploit the knowledge that you have to go to the old thing? And there's some simple algorithms that you can follow in order to solve that problem optimally. One of these algorithms you can characterize in terms of sort of like think about the best plausible experience that you could have at the new place. So be optimistic about the quality of the new place. And if that optimistic estimate is better than your estimate of the quality of the meal you'll get elsewhere, then you should try the new place.
对吧。但是，如果你相当确信你在其他地方会吃得很香，那么你甚至不需要那样做。因此，当你下次不得不选择餐馆时，你现在就可以使用这个算法。有许多类似的事情，事实上，只要知道存在最优解，就意味着你甚至不必去考虑它。而且你不必担心你做了什么，因为你知道你正在做
Right. But if you're pretty confident you're going to get a great meal elsewhere, then you don't even need to do that. So that algorithm is now something that you can use when you, you know, next have to choose a restaurant. And there's a bunch of things like this where, in fact, just knowing that there is an optimal solution means that you don't even have to think about it. And you don't have to worry about what you do because you know that you're doing the
最好的事情，即使它结果并不理想。因此，对于那些花很多时间思考决策的人来说，知道其实你可以遵循这些最优策略，会带来一些宽慰。不过有趣的是，也存在一些比这些情况稍微复杂一些的情况，我们在其中面临着一个稍微更具挑战性的问题。例如，比如说餐馆的质量随着时间推移而发生变化。这是一个计算机科学家还没有解决的问题，但人类仍然很擅长解决。
best thing, even if it doesn't work out. And so for people who, you know, sort of like spend a lot of time thinking about decisions, there's a little bit of relief in knowing that, in fact, you can follow these optimal strategies. The interesting thing, though, is that there are also cases that are a little bit more complex than these cases, where we sort of, you know, now have a slightly more challenging problem. For example, say if the quality of the restaurants changes over time. This is a problem which the computer scientists haven't solved, but that humans are still pretty good at solving.
所以另一个好消息是，无论如何，你的直觉对于解决这些问题其实都相当不错。因此，即使你没有遵循最优策略，你可能也在做一些非常明智的事情。通过观察人类所做的那些明智的事情，我们实际上可以为让计算机解决这类问题设计出更好的算法。所以这基本上就是去意识到你是如何做决定的。我的意思是，我们的大脑就是那样运作的，虽然有时我想你会感到沮丧，然后你就会
And so the other good bit of news is that your human intuitions are actually pretty good for solving these problems anyway. And so even if you're not following the optimal strategy, you're probably doing something that's pretty sensible. And by looking at those kinds of sensible things that humans do, we can actually work out better algorithms for making computers solve these kinds of problems. So it's kind of being aware of how you're making the decisions, basically. I mean, our minds are working that way, although sometimes I think you get frustrated and you just
抛硬币，说今天吃墨西哥菜。今天不吃法国菜。事实证明，在某些情况下，抛硬币实际上是一个最优策略。所以这是解决探索与利用权衡的一个好方法，你知道，有时候你愿意抛硬币。我唯一要说的是，你抛硬币的频率应该随着时间的推移而递减。因此，你在一个城市呆的时间越长，你采取这种随机行动的概率就应该越低。结果证明，这也是一个最优算法。好吧，让我们谈谈一个非常宏观的问题。
flip a coin and say it's Mexican. today, it's not going to be French. So it turns out flipping a coin is actually an optimal strategy under some circumstances. So that's a good way of solving the explorer exploit tradeoff where you, you know, some of the time are willing to flip a coin. The only thing that I would say is that the rate at which you flip a coin should be decreasing over time. So the longer you stay in a city, you should be taking that random action with lower probability. And then that turns out to be an optimal algorithm too. Well, let's talk about one really big picture question.
我想很多人都在问，特别是当谷歌的那位科学家认为他的程序变得有知觉之后。我的意思是，知觉会成为可能吗？在你看来，你认为我们能够制造出具有自我意识的人工智能吗？我的意思是，什么是知觉？是的，这是一个大问题。这也是一个我可以说我并不经常去思考的问题。
I think a lot of people are asking, especially after that scientist at Google, thought that his program was becoming sentient. I mean, will sentience be possible? In your view, do you think that we're going to be able to make an artificial intelligence that has self-awareness? I mean, what is sentience? Yeah, that's a big question. It's also one that I would say, I don't think about a lot.
因为我不确定它对我们对待这些系统的方法、我们与它们的互动方式或我们看待事物的方式有什么区别。所以我要说的第一件事是，我们不应该期望人工智能系统会
Because I'm not sure what difference it makes to the way that we approach these systems or our interactions with them or the way that we think about things. So the first thing I'd say is that we shouldn't expect AI systems to be. be like people. And the reason why we shouldn't expect AI systems to be like people is the constraints that characterize human cognition are different from the constraints that characterize the circumstances under which AI is being engineered, right? So humans are this weird special case of intelligence that comes from our sort of biological heritage of having limited lifespans, limited amounts of computation, and limited communication, right? And so when you take those constraints away, you're going to get systems that can intelligently solve problems.
像人一样。我们不应该期望人工智能系统像人的原因在于，塑造人类认知的约束条件与设计人工智能的环境所具备的约束条件是不同的，对吧？因此，人类是这种奇怪的特殊智能案例，它源于我们拥有有限寿命、有限计算能力和有限沟通能力的生物学传统，对吧。因此，当你把这些限制移除后，你就会得到能够智能解决问题的系统。
They're not necessarily going to solve problems in ways that look human-like. They're going to solve problems in ways that are different because they're not operating under the same constraints. Right. So when AlphaGo was created, which was this AI system, which could beat the world's best human players in the game of Go, that system was able to plan out into the future. much further than any human being can plan.
它们不一定以看起来像人类的方式解决问题。它们将以不同的方式解决问题，因为它们不在相同的约束条件下运作。对吧。因此，当AlphaGo被创造出来时，这是一个人工智能系统，它可以在围棋比赛中击败世界上最优秀的人类玩家，该系统能够向未来规划。比任何人类所能规划的都要远得多。
Right? It could plan out, you know, many, many steps into the future. And as a consequence, what it was doing was just, it was always taking the move that would sort of, was guaranteed to give it, you know, a small advantage all the way out in the future. And that doesn't look a lot like human gameplay because humans can't plan that flower out into the future, right? Humans can only plan over a limited horizon. And so we do things like setting goals and sub-goals and sort of thinking hierarchically and sort of
对吧？它可以向未来规划很多很多步。因此，它所做的只是，它总是采取那种在未来一路保证能给它带来微小优势的移动。这看起来很不像人类的游戏方式，因为人类无法在未来规划得那么远，对吧？人类只能在有限的视野内进行规划。所以我们会做一些事情，比如设定目标和子目标，进行分层思考，以及由于我们认知中的这种限制而分解问题。如果你消除了这种限制，那么你就可以通过更多的规划来解决问题，对吧？这正是人工智能系统所生活的世界。它们能够找到与我们试图解决的问题不同种类的解决方案，因为它们不在相同的约束条件下运作。因此，许多我们视为智能特征的事物，实际上是人类大脑必须解决的计算问题的特征。
breaking down problems because of that constraint in our cognition. And if you remove that constraint, then you can just solve the problem by planning more, right? And that's kind of the world that the AI systems live in. They're able to find different kinds of solutions to the problems that we are trying to solve because they're not operating under the same constraints. And so a lot of the things that we view as characteristic of intelligence are really characteristic of the kinds of computational problems that human minds have to solve. and the AI systems that we're going to interact with are just going to be different kinds of intelligences.
我们将与之互动的人工智能系统只是不同种类的智能。它们在各种方面都将是异质的，我们必须建立我们自己关于这些系统是什么样子的、与它们互动是什么感觉的新内部认知模型，而不要期望它们像人类一样。结合你目前对人工智能的了解，你认为它将如何在未来几年和长远
They're going to be alien in various kinds of ways, and we have to just build our own new internal cognitive models of what these systems are like and what it's like to interact with them without expecting them to be like human beings. Knowing what you know about AI at this point, how do you think it's going to change our lives in the next few years and in the long time? term? I mean, there's a lot of doom and gloom out there at the moment about AI taking jobs and, you know, maybe destroying the world. And, you know, there's a whole spectrum of opinions that you can hear as well as, I think, very serious and legitimate concerns about, you know, who is being represented in AI and who is represented in the data sets that it's trained on and what the consequences are that that has for power in our societies, right? And so I think all of those concerns are things that are worth thinking about as we interact with
未来改变我们的生活？我的意思是，目前有很多关于人工智能抢走工作甚至可能毁灭世界的悲观言论。而且，你知道，你可以听到各种各样的观点，同时我认为还有非常严肃和合法的担忧，关于谁被代表在人工智能中，谁被代表在它所训练的数据集中，以及这对我们社会中的权力意味着什么后果，对吧？因此，我认为所有这些担忧都是在我们进行互动时值得思考的事情。
these kinds of systems and we see them deployed in our societies. We should be asking questions about what the potential consequences are. Who are the people who are involved in this and being represented by it? At the same time, I think it's good for us to be optimistic about what the positive consequences of these kinds of systems might be. So, for example, in some work they did with collaborators who have been analyzing the game of Go since AlphaGo was introduced, in that work, what we actually found was that the creativity of the human Go players, as measured by the novelties, as measured by the novelty of the moves that they were producing was actually increased by the presence of this AI system in their environment.
这类系统被部署在我们的社会中，我们应该质疑潜在的后果是什么。涉及其中并代表这些系统的人是谁？与此同时，我认为我们应该对这些系统可能产生的积极后果保持乐观。例如，在他们与自 AlphaGo 推出以来一直在分析围棋游戏的合作者所做的一些工作中，我们实际发现的是，通过新颖性衡量的围棋人类玩家的创造力，通过他们所产生招式的新颖性衡量，由于环境中这个人工智能系统的存在而实际上有所提高。
So it's not the case that any human go player is able to beat the AI system reliably as a consequence of those innovations. But having this other kind of intelligence enter their community led the humans to explore interesting new directions that they hadn't explored before and to make their own new discoveries. And so that's my hope, is that we're able to find a way to interact with these systems and to live with them and to integrate them into our communities
因此，并非任何人类围棋玩家由于这些创新而能够可靠地击败人工智能系统。但是，让另一种智能进入他们的社区，促使人类探索他们以前未曾探索过的有趣新方向，并做出他们自己的新发现。因此，我的希望是，我们能够找到一种与这些系统互动、与它们共存并将它们融入我们社区的方法
that allows us to achieve more than we're otherwise able to achieve as human beings. And so it's really an augmentation of what it is to be human and what it is that we're able to do as humans, rather than something which is a replacement for human beings. So final question to wrap things up, what are you studying right now? What are the big questions that you're trying to answer at the moment? Well, a lot of the big questions that we're focused on
这使我们能够取得比作为人类原本所能取得的更多的成就。因此，这实际上是对人类本质以及我们作为人类所能做的事情的一种增强，而不是对人类的取代。那么，作为结束的最后一个问题，你目前在研究什么？你目前试图回答的重大问题是什么？嗯，我们关注的很多重大问题
are really these questions about these distinctively human aspects of intelligence. So what I want to understand are these things that human beings do that are still challenges for AI systems. And these things that I think we could argue are sort of characteristic of what makes us human. So we do a lot of work trying to understand how it is that humans are able to learn from small amounts of data
实际上是关于智能中这些鲜明的人类特质的问题。所以我想了解的是人类所做的事情，这些事情对人工智能系统来说仍然是挑战。我认为这些事情可以说是我们人类特征的某种体现。因此，我们做了大量工作，试图了解人类如何能够从少量数据中学习
and put those same kinds of abilities into machines. We do work, which is asking, how is it that people make efficient decisions about how to use their cognitive resources? And again, how that's something that could potentially inform the kinds of algorithms that we use for solving problems like planning.
并将同样的能力赋予机器。我们开展了一项工作，探讨人们如何就如何使用其认知资源做出高效的决策。同样，这也是如何为我们用来解决规划等问题的算法提供参考的潜在途径。
And finally, how it is that humans interact with one another to achieve more than they're able to achieve individually. And I think that last piece is particularly important in the world that we're now entering, where those interactions are not just interactions with human beings, but also interactions with other kinds of intelligent systems and trying to understand how we can structure those interactions and how it is that humans are able to make the most of our AI partners
最后，人类如何相互作用以取得比单打独斗更多的成就。我认为最后一部分在我们即将进入的世界中尤其重要，在这个世界中，这些互动不仅与人类互动，还与其他种类的智能系统互动，并试图了解我们如何构建这些互动，以及人类如何能够充分利用我们的 AI 伙伴
as we go into this future together. Well, Dr. Griffiths, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting, and I appreciate your optimistic outlook. Thank you. It's been great. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts, and please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology
当我们共同迈向这个未来时。格里菲斯博士，我要感谢你今天加入我们。这真的非常有趣，我很欣赏你乐观的前景。谢谢你。这太棒了。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）之前的节目，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：Speaking of Psychology
at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
at APA.org。《心理学对话》由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔达扬（Chris Condayan）。感谢收听美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。